Hình thửa đổi đăng tự bước chiến khai hệ thống camera giám sát ứng dụng chỉ tự nhiên tạo,
ở ai. Hương tối mục tiêu thay thế cảnh sát xa thông làm dịm vụ ngoài đường.
Sẽ dự mù hình còn lý xa thông và đối thị hiện đại, đồng bộ hiệu quà.
Dự kiến đến ngày 18, hệ thông sẽ được bận hành đầy đủ,
có phần giám thiệu tối đá việc mũ chi lực lượng cảnh xa xa thông trước tiêu tại các viên phố,
nú gào trọng điểm.
Hình này, lực lượng công an thành phố đá hoàn thành việc lắp đặt và đưa vào sử dụng 2,5 mốt
camera AI, tích hợp mùi nhóm chức năng, bao gồm dễn khuôn mặt,
biển số phương tịch, phát hiện hành vi vi phạm xa thông, giám sát an ninh chự tự và mối trường đối thị.
Các các mirrora có khả năng qua xa tự xa, hòa đậu trong điều kiện thời tiết khác nghiệp,
cho phép dễn dự tự tự tại khoảng cách lớn, phục vụ hiệu quà công tác chỉ vì
đưa hành tự trung tâm điều thiệt. Hệ thông không chỉ vụ vụ quà lý xa thông mà còn 4 trở giám sát tình trạng o những môi trường,
phát hiện vào vi nhận hành vi xa ra không đúng lưỡi quy định, vi phạm chật tự vẻ hệ,
tự đó năng cao ý tức và hành vi của mình rất trong việc bảo vệ môi trường và xe dự văn mình đô thiệt.
Vóa thầu tiếp theo dự kiến hoàn thành vào quy bàn năm 2020, mở giọc độ phụ của camera trên tòa địa bàn,
năng cao năng lực sự lý tự động quá.
Hí hoàn thiệt hệ thông sẽ có phần thiết lập nền nếp đô thiệt bảo đam ăn tòa ra thông, ăn ninh chật tự.
Đông thư dạm tại cho lực lượng chức năng và năng cao dự quà công tác của lý nhận nước trên địa bàn tụ đô.